[Musik]
mit 67 von anfang november bis ende
dezember den zurückgezogenen stützpunkt
bezogen im raum swisssign weil es
wirklich so schlecht war dass man von
vor 2000 auf 1800 oder 1700 meter zurück
genau wissen wie haben sie das den
datenzugang gehabt und damals
sogenannten ground das ist gesteht der
anzug der als über das internet anzeigte
zwiebel system aber dass noch immer zum
und dann über die saucen cloud ist auch
nur erahnen zu kursen und noch am tag
große anerkennung und mode hand in hand
finger links 100 noch mal zurückkommt
und drüber segelt durch anspannung und
da was er so du hast aufpassen müssen
dass die eine freie stelle gab das
weinhaus sofort broncos gehabt und ich
hab das ohne glück gehabt es war in der
gleichen zeit hat der österreichische
skiverband dsv meisterschaft
obwohl die dort bei der neuen lift und
das angebaute das kalisalz weg fort und
da habe ich gesehen dass db force
staaten haben sie auslösen und davor
dass eine salbe gehabt dass es nur von
der deutschen werbung gewesen eine frist
zur zeit aber mit bhs geleitet wird ist
geklärt aber dass ausblick und hab mir
leid überhaupt die hand sowas noch ein
ausser dass es bereits ab können damit
und mir eigentlich erfrierungen haben
wir keinen kopf
die backkunst haben jeweils eine stärke
von 3 mount gehabt und der control
vorgang ist auch an so durchgeführt
worden dass man irgendeine person
genährt wird wächst als gesehen haben er
hatte eine auf dem platz geben und hat
ein aufschub
vorher seien aber der anderen zwei
sicherungs bussen und deckung kommen und
aufgrund beim einschreiben haben die
noch bei unserem ab auf dem hof geladen
worden als noch im vor durch repariert
und buntes t g 8 15 und lauten knall und
das war die erste wohnung und aufgrund
dieses gesetzes ist eine leistungshoch
in die knochen kann das sofort die hand
abgerissen
was dann passiert ist das geht auch an
einer woche drei stehen ließ sich eine
verletzte welche verstaucht hat und wir
haben aber dazu muss nur keine zweite
verschalung den kopf zweimal gestern mit
dem planeten kann
es ist mir nichts anderes über bremen es
wird also mir dann akteur obergurgl ist
nach dem gießkannen binder und es ist
meist bei -3 skype dann hat aber der den
sturz an handschuhen verloren und soll
dennis meinhardt und jemanden meine
heute sorgt mit einer fahne umwickelt
dass man die hand genommen hat und so
haben noch in den haag wird bis ober
gurgel am fundort bekannten vater zweier
kinder nummer und hatten auch immer noch
ins gefährt